There was a time long ago...
...when women ruled with unparalleled power,
as warriors, queens, mothers of nations.
And there was
none among them more iconic
than Cleopatra.
I would die for Egypt.
What would you die for?
I am Isis. I am a god.
As long as she's alive,
she is the pharaoh.
My father's will
names me coruler of Egypt.
Julius Caesar
is aware that Cleopatra
is one of the best educated women
in the Mediterranean.
He wants to be king
to Cleopatra's queen.
There is no future without the past.
She was using these relationships
with Mark Antony
to protect herself and her country.
There is no Rome without Egypt.
Cleopatra was trying
to save the country that she loved
from destruction.
I did what I had to do
to protect what is mine!
This is a woman exercising power.
Cleopatra was a Ptolemaic ruler.
The very first Ptolemy
is a general of Alexander the Great.
It's possible that she was an Egyptian.
I imagine her
to have curly hair like me
and similar skin color.
I remember
my grandmother saying to me,
"I don't care
what they tell you in school,
Cleopatra was Black."
She has become an icon.
I'm a god.
Queen of Kings!
Her story resonates
with every woman.